vamos a explorar lo que significa restar
números así es que vamos a pensar
cuántos eran 4 0 4
cuánto será 4 menos
esto implicaría que empezamos con cuatro
objetos y a esos cuatro objetos le
quitaremos o les estaremos 3
así es que déjenme les dibujo cuatro
objetos morados uno
y uno más 4
1 2 3 4 estos serán los cuatro objetos
con los que iniciaremos y si decimos que
le restamos tres de estos objetos lo que
voy a hacer es quitar o restar tres de
ellos quitaré uno
3 es importante que nos demos cuenta que
he quitado 1 2 y 3 de acuerdo al número
que aquí nos indica la resta a 4 objetos
le estoy restando 3 así es que la
pregunta es con cuántos objetos me estoy
quedando pues puedo decir que me estoy
quedando con este objeto un solo objeto
4 menos 3 será igual a 1 escribimos eso
4 menos tres es igual a 1
o sea cuatro objetos le he quitado o
restado tres me quedaré solo con uno que
esta es nuestra respuesta que tal
sencillo cierto vamos a hacer un ejemplo
un poquito más complicado déjenme les
hago espacio ahora investigaremos cuánto
será 5
menos
25 - 2
vamos a plantearlo de otra manera
qué números era yo no tengo idea qué
números eran
igual a 52 este signo de interrogación
nos indica que no conocemos cuál será
este número así es que vamos a
representarlo gráficamente como lo
habíamos hecho hace un momento hace rato
2 resultó bastante sencillo vamos a
volver a hacerlo colocaremos 1
cinco objetos tenemos cinco objetos a
los cuales le restamos o le quitaremos
dos y quitaré entonces 12 volvemos a
marcar que he quitado 12 de los cinco
objetos iniciales me he quedado solo con
estos que están aquí vamos a marcarlos
estos han sido los objetos con los que
me quedé al quitarle dos objetos a
nuestros cinco objetos iniciales bueno
pues me quedan entonces 12
3 podemos decir entonces que este signo
de interrogación realmente equivale a 3
que son los tres objetos con los que nos
hemos quedado después de haber eliminado
los dos a los cinco originales vamos
entonces a borrar nuestro signo de
interrogación y colocaremos que 5 menos
2 es igual a 3 o podemos decir que 3 es
igual a 5 menos 2
ambos son correctos